Dana's been getting me into country  music a little bit it's starting to warm  up a little bit I'm kinda starting to  feel it well I like this new artist her  name is Jillian Carter Ally and she is a  country-music sensation was actually  named top ten new country artists you  need to know 2017 by Rolling Stone and  she's got this new single out  it's called souvenirs take a listen  [Music]  there she is and Gillian I think has  joined us today  there she is so you can grab the new  song over at Apple music or Spotify got  a great beat so it doesn't approve but I  love it and I think Travis Meadows was  in that list too right I think so yes  okay so I am paying attention to my  worlds expanding I'm in country music  that we're gonna get culture to him yet